Drew Barrymore's not the only celeb
who's faced scabbing allegations Kim
Kardashian was called out for literally
crossing the picket line to get to the
American Horror Story set a wga strike
Captain tweeted that while they were
picketing in New York City Kim crossed
the line to get to set and then she even
tweeted about being on set to which
another member of the writer's Guild
replied and called her out Bill Maher
said that he thinks a lot of what the
writers are acting for is kooky he
basically said that writers shouldn't
believe that they're owed a living as
writers because this is show business
and that's just how it is which is a
terrible take and then a few weeks after
that he announced that he was going to
continue production on his talk show
Real Time with Bill Maher but without
any writers he said he's going to honor
the strike though by cutting out the
monologue and the desk piece and like
any editorial pieces and just focus on
the talk show aspect of the show but
many people are still calling him Scott
for continuing production anyway and at
the beginning of the actor strike
Stephen Amell from Arrow said that he
supports the union but not the strike he
actually said that striking was a
reductive negotiating tactic but after
the internet ended up dragging him
relentlessly he ended up supporting the
strike